in the last video we saw that if Ben's
shoe company's stock prices at trading
at twenty one dollars and fifty cents
per share and if Ben's
shoe company has ten thousand shares and
we saw that over here on the left if it
had 10,000 shares actually both of the
shoe companies had ten thousand shares
then the market is essentially valuing
the equity of Ben's shoe company at two
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
even though the book value of the equity
was a hundred thirty-five thousand
dollars what I want to do in this video
is think about what does that mean or
how should we perceive the market's
value of the assets of Ben's a shoe
company that we can also think about
Jason's shoe company so remember assets
are equal to assets are equal to
liabilities plus shareholders equity so
if all of a sudden the market value of
the equity the market capitalization for
Ben's shoe company is two hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars that's the
equity part right over here this is the
equity and the only liability that Ben's
shoe company had was this five thousand
dollars in accounts payable so let me
show you that right over here
he had this five thousand dollars in
accounts payable also depicted over
there so the only liability is this five
thousand dollars so the liabilities plus
the equity in the case of Ben's company
is two hundred fifteen thousand plus
five thousand dollars so this piece
right over here is two hundred and
twenty thousand dollars now you might
remember from previous videos that the
book value of the assets in Ben's
company are only a hundred and forty
thousand dollars twenty thousand of cash
hundred thousand dollars of inventory
twenty thousand dollars this isn't
equity this is equipment I should call
it this is e equipment twenty thousand
dollars of equipment so the question is
is what makes up the gap here when when
we think about the market value of the
equity cuz remember this piece right
here only adds up to one hundred and
forty thousand dollars but our total
assets are the market's perception of
the total assets of the company and are
essentially what it's willing to pay for
the equity plus the liability so the
market is saying that Ben's assets the
assets in that company are worth 220,000
dollars so what makes the difference and
let's even better let's assume that that
man has actually done a good job of
saying the market value of his inventory
the market value of his equipment well
what the markets saying in this
situation and this is actually what it
what tends to happen where the market
value or or in general the market value
of a company's equity tends to be higher
than the book values that the company
saying is that this company has some
type of intangibles things that you
really can't put a finger on or touch or
feel or or hold but it makes it makes
this company's assets or this company
has more than just the sum of its parts
or there's more to this company than
just the equipment's the inventory in
the cash it might be Ben's management
expertise it might be a certain way they
have of doing business it might be a
certain location they have it might be
their assortment who knows what it has
but the market is saying that the
combination of this plus all of the
expertise and how the business is
organized means that it actually has
more assets than are on the books and
the same thing is true of Jason's
company when they assign 120 thousand
dollar market cap there this is 120
thousand dollars in equity market value
of equity
he has another hundred and five thousand
dollars in liabilities so the markets
valuing their equity plus liabilities at
one hundred and or two hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars
is that right 120 plus 100 plus five so
two hundred and twenty-five thousand so
once again their mark the valving all of
the assets at two hundred and
twenty-five thousand because assets are
equal to liabilities
these are the liabilities right here
plus equity so once again they're saying
there's something above and beyond the
hundred and forty thousand dollars that
makes this company special and an
interesting thing to think about and
we'll address it in the next video is
which one is a better deal considering
that these companies are pretty pretty
similar